en plus j'ai envie de dire mais en plus
car d'être intéressant c'est celui là
c'est le pot cohen quatre pros le poème
quatre pros j'ai du mal avec les
appellations shiomi alors on sait que
pau koichiro mis dans certains pays ce
sont deux entités séparées en france est
la même en tout cas c'est xiaomi qui
distribue pokou et pour autant on a des
références qui sont souvent un peu
compliqué poko m4 pro que veut dire le m
on allait poko f on à l'époque au x
journal poko m vous avez présenté les
dernières lepoko m3 que je re situer
plus dans l'entrée de gamme ici on est à
2 130 et 260 et quelques euros on sera
plus soit dans le haut de gamme de
l'entrée de gamme soit dans l'entrée de
gamme du milieu de gamme vous le situer
comme vous voulez en tout cas ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'on va regarder ce que ce
poème 4 open et c'est intéressant parce
que là on est une appellation pro alors
payer dernière sur le m300 mais pas
d'appellation pro du moins en france le
smartphone est intéressant il ya des
choses qui ont été améliorées revue et
corrigée par rapport à ce qu'on ne
veuille dernière avec le poke om3 il ya
des trucs qui sont je le dire par un peu
en dessous mais un peu différent je vais
tous vous détailler pour savoir si ce
poko m4 pro vaut le coup si les faits
pour vous pas et je vous le dis tout de
suite d'entrée de billets comme ça vous
le saurez pourquoi l'institut comme un
smartphone qui est destiné plutôt pour
un public assez jeune plutôt orienté
multimédia plutôt orienté gaming
visionnage films séries et on peut venir
jouer avec on va regarder si c'est vrai
mais ben oui ces buts
voilà pas réussi la boîte alors je vous
montrais scarlett et rieur c'est très
sommaire
poko ok ça c'est là en feront le
smartphone qui est positionné ici mais
bon moi je lui ai enlevé vous en
douterez et à l'intérieur bloc de charge
vous avez votre cap pour venir le
charger en usb usb appui si vous avez
des petits écouteurs que je n'ai pas
mais vous vous aurez donc ça c'est bien
donc voilà pour la boîte voilà
maintenant le smart la smart phone il
est sympa première chose que j'aime bien
effectivement bien c'est très différent
par rapport à ce qu'on a sur le reste du
marché on va le gros module photo poko
sosa aussi rigolo sale type un sale type
énormément mais ça fonctionne plutôt pas
mal pourquoi pas design by poko fait
pourquoi il vous dit ben c'est du pot qu
on le dessine nous mêmes c'est du pot
codéine et par coco bon ok on aura
compris celle du pot cofepac poko ça
marche ce que j'aime bien par contre
c'est ce dos la casse c'est doux avec ce
côté un peu granuleux il ya un côté très
soyeux granuleux sympa à tripoter on a
envie de toucher toute la journée alors
attention ça reste un smartphone
calmez-vous tout va bien se passer le
module photo assez sympa alors c'est
très rigolo parce que l'année dernière
j'avais un petit peu râlé en disant
votre caméra principale c'est le 48
mégapixels et puis on avait deux
capteurs un point mode portrait de 2
mégapixels et un pour la macro 2
mégapixels et s'ils ont vraiment changé
la configuration on va s'arrêter
quelques instants parce que vous avez un
grand-angle et un ultra grand temps que
c'est intéressant c'est vraiment
intéressant ce qu'ils ont fait donc on
va se le tchèque est tout à l'heure sur
le reste design est assez sommaire
bouton de volume bouton pour l'allumer
pour l'éteindre haut parleurs prise jack
de quoi le recharger en usb c'est un
micro votre tiroir de cartes sim à
double s'initient à 5 g de l'infrarouge
micro pour la réduction de bruit et puis
votre petit haut parleur qui est planqué
là ici on va retrouver un petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui déverrouille
mais très très vite un veau pose à peine
votre doigt vous êtes déjà déverrouiller
ça c'est quand même super actif et très
très bien et puis vous avez ici une
petite caméra qui est planqué là on va
la vendre dans les paramètres sur tout
ce qui est différent par rapport à ce
qu'on avait une dernière est ce qui est
aussi intéressant c'est une amère
c'était voyez une espèce de petit
renfoncement comme une espèce du bouton
intégrer ça venait augmenter le bord
noir en eau ici ils ont fait le choix de
le faire vraiment différemment et de
faire juste et bien un petit point son
centre ça fonctionne on retrouve un
manteau en bas c'est pas trop proéminent
ça va ça fonctionne et ça reste cohérent
sur un smartphone dans cette gamme de
prix il n'est pas particulièrement lourd
il fait 195 g ça ça me conviendra
également dispo en trois couleurs alors
moi j'ai un petit bleu ici qui est très
jolie l'existant devoir est également en
jeu on doit retrouver à l'avant un
corning gorilla glass 3 ici on a les
crocs une diagonale de 6 6 pouces c'est
du full hd plus avec un taux de
rafraîchissement adaptatif de 90 hier
puisqu'on parle de multimédia va bien
parlé ici l'expérience audio parce que
regarder un film il série et je vois un
jeu si vous n'entendez rien aussi la
qualité n'est pas à la hauteur ça serait
un peu dommage je vous le dis
directement comme ça et haut parleur que
vous avez là sont assez mauvais très
médium extrêmement médium
[Musique]
après on est sur un smartphone à 230
euros donc bon pour remettre tout en
perspective voyez la france a saturé et
sait pas où falloir y en a un truc
intéressant savoir également c'est que
votre par leur principal on s'en doute
rails les plans qu'avez vous à des siens
deuxième haut parleurs sert parlant de
renforts que haut-parleurs ici vous avez
sur le côté va ajouter un peu en
spécialisation mais en encore plus sur
le médium que sur le médium c'est donc
de l'extrême médium donc on va pas
profiter de la meilleure expérience
lorsque vous allez bien l'utiliser à la
main avec les haut parleurs si on veut
aller plus loin pouvez le faire en
bluetooth ici on a une amélioration par
rapport à la version précédente on est
en blue tooth 5.0 merci à vous tous 5.0
sur le m3 et vous avez une prise jack
qui est planqué juste ici en eau qui
vous permettra de venir brancher un
casque si vous le souhaitez donc si on
reprend leurs cibles multimédia gaming
c'est vrai mais ça va faire davantage
avec un casque et une fois de plus fait
attention avec un casque ne poussait pas
le son trop fort vous rendez pas sourd
c'est important le choix a été fait ici
de tourner et non pas sur un qualcomm
snapdragon
on est sereins médiathèque dit man city
108-110 qui est gravé en scylla nos
maîtres et surtout ici et bien c'est un
soft qui est 5 g je devais avoir 4 ou 6
giga de ram en effet d'hédiard 4x un peu
comme ce qu'on avait l'année dernière un
smartphone qui réagit bien qu'il n'y ait
pas qui marche plutôt pas mal le
stockage on est plus sur les fs 2 points
en mai sur le fs 2.2 c'est à dire à un
poil plus vite en lecture et en écriture
on a soit 64 soit 128 go de stockage
extensible jusqu'à intérêt en termes de
performances un smartphone qui
fonctionne bien que ce soit pour du
gaming pour venir scrollé on a quelque
chose qui est efficace en plus pour le
gaming vous dit vous êtes 82 wiertz et
vous avez un taux d'échantillonnage taxi
de 240 hertz donc ont un smartphone qui
n'est pas une bête de compet pour le
gaming mais ce qu'il fait il le fait
bien alors c'est marrant parce que la
dernière fois que pourquoi une 3,9 une
grosse batterie de 6000 militants pérard
et des airois où c'est vraiment un truc
intéressant parce que pour consommateurs
quand on voit des chiffres aussi énorme
on se dit qu'on va en avoir pour son
argent alors c'est sûr que l'autonomie
devient pas que de la batterie ça vient
du processeur derrière là on n'a pas un
snapdragon on est chez mediatek et ils
nous en met une batterie de 5000 milles
et en période versus 6000 millions par
année dernière après notre peau qui est
intéressant c'est le bloc de charge de
33 watts on avait dû 22,5 croître
l'année dernière avec le m3 ça ira un
peu plus vite alors ce qui est
intéressant c'est que 22 points 5 watts
pour remplir une batterie de signer
millions alors ça m'était pas mal de
temps quand même là une 5000 millan
perreur avait dû 33 watts ça ira tout de
suite beaucoup mieux donc l'autonomie
vous attendez à une journée et demie et
si vous êtes vraiment dans la cible a
beaucoup joué une journée pas plus mais
vous allez le recharger rapidement parce
que vous rechargez ou un peu moins d'une
heure à 100% bon après de recharger pas
à 100% je vous ai fait une vidéo pour
vous parler justement de la recharge des
smartphones vous ne décharge et pas en
dessous de 20 % voulu recharger pas au
dessus de 80 % entre 20 et 80
l'expérience logiciel c'est dû me wade
12.5 pour beaucoup basé sur l'android
rose sans s'y attendre et on va
retrouver les grands classiques il ya un
bien révolutionnaire ici c'est
fonctionnel ça marche bien il ya deux
trois petites choses qui sont un petit
peu bizarre j'ai vu un petit un petit
bug lorsque je suis là voyez par exemple
pour le nfc il me met un message dans
une langue que je ne connais pas je sais
pas pourquoi ça peut être corrigée je
viens le déverrouiller et bien je
reviens ici sur la partie connexion et
partage et comme je ne n'arrive pas ya
le message est bien je ne sais pas ce
qui se passe sinon vous allez retrouver
si votre semble de contrôler votre
tiroir d'applications classe et ensuite
par catégorie ou communication
divertissement vous avez les photos la
lecture les achats les jeux bref c'est
assez bien fait niveau photo c'est là
que c'est intéressant vous avez deux
capteurs à l'arrière et non pas trois
capteurs j'avais vraiment pesté un anr
en disant qu'ils se moquent de nous les
derniers en date à 1,48 mégapixels et
puis deux capteurs fois de la macro et
mode portrait donc on se disait on à 3
capteur à l'arrière mais franchement ça
sert à rien en avait un alors ici sont
venus améliorer un peu la propose ça je
trouve ça intéressant donc on passe d'un
capteur utile et danner à deux capteurs
utile cette année à savoir vous avez un
grand temps de 50 méga pixels touvre f
1.8 et vous avez un ultra grand-angle de
8 mégapixels tour f 2.2 avec un champ de
vision 219 degrés même si c'est pas là
dessus qu'on va aller le plus loin terme
de photos on n'est pas sur un photophone
pour qu elle est vraiment pas accès pour
la photo poko et accès pour l'expérience
de gaming et multimédia pour un public
jeune et vous avez en plus une petite
caméra à l'avant qui est planqué ici ce
qu'il faut savoir et et c'est que vous
n'avez aucune stabilisation optique
lorsque vous avez bien faire des photos
que comme moi bien vous avez la
tremblade vous rendez compte qu'en terme
de crash tests et bien moment eh ben ça
ne passe pas mais ça c'est moi et moi je
suis un très très bon crash test pour ça
voilà les photos que j'ai fait avec son
smartphone alors regardez en termes de
couleurs c'est assez terne il n'y a pas
de stabilisation s'est tout de suite
assez floue tous les arbres là c'est pas
terrible on n'est pas sur un appareil
qui est optimisé pour venir faire de la
photo autant de regards des choses pas
mal en termes de gaming et multimédia en
termes de photos s'est pas vraiment son
fort l'ultra grand angle est pas mieux
il devient assez imprécis les couleurs
bref c'est pas beau pouvait venir zoomer
dans x 2 mai regarder certains devenir
zoomer pour zoomer dans un truc alors je
dirais qu'on est à 50 méga pixels on
peut venir rouler dedans vu que le
fichier de base est pas extraordinaire
en revenant je vous mets dedans ça va
pas s'améliorer pour autant et on peut
faire un zoom x 10 mais bon pour refaire
n'en fais pas de zoom pas 10 ou encore
la regarder c'est pareil c'est très
imprécis c'est très flou alors moi je
tremble évidemment ça n'aide pas mais je
fêterai mon crash test vous verrez tout
de suite qu en termes de résultats et
bien vous aurez pas un truc
extraordinaire là c'est pareil et
l'ultra grand temps là bas c'est pas ou
du tout en menant au n'est pas mieux et
en se rapprochant qu'en plus pas mieux
la caméra de celle fille pour que ça
vient vraiment lycées au niveau des
pôles alors on aura des souvenirs bien
évidemment mais il faut pas être trop
exigeant regardez là c'est pareil de la
même manière le bâtiment derrière il est
cramé l'ultra grand temps que c'est
pareil les hautes lumières ça s'arrache
tous les côtés c'est vraiment pas beau
du tout là je vous ai pris une photo en
50 méga pixels mais vous voyez comme
c'est pas stabilisée ben on a un truc
qui est panne est due tout est là c'est
la même chose en 50 méga pixels ray sera
la moins pire de toutes celles là on
peut venir regarder un peu d'en devenir
zoom et un peu mais pas plus on peut
faire quelques photos si vous avez
vraiment les très bonnes conditions de
la bonne lumière si vous exposez bien
s'il n'y a pas de contre-jour c'est tout
est maîtrisé mais au-delà de ça pour la
photo je vous recommande pas mais on
pourrait se dire pour la vidéo c'est
mieux et bien non de la même manière
comme vous n'avez pas le stabilisation
et bien sa bouche de tous les côtés ce
n'est pas du tout agréable à regarder
donc c'est pas un smartphone qu'on va
prendre par exemple pourrait faire de la
création sur un tick tock sur instagram
pour deyris et pas du tout un smartphone
qui est dédié pour ça c'est vraiment un
smartphone qui va être dédiés uniquement
pour venir jouer à des jeux regarder des
films des séries pour venir être sur vos
différents réseaux sociaux en visionnage
pas en créations si vous voulez faire de
la création lepoko m4 prod est vraiment
pas fait pour vous bien vous allez de la
5g si vous avez une double carte sim 5g
donc si vous avez besoin de deux
abonnements 5g et bien vous allez
pouvoir la voir ici dans ce téléphone
donc ça c'est intéressant vous avez en
plus du nfc pour le paiement
dématérialisé de l'infrarouge si vous
souhaitez utiliser comme une
télécommande pourquoi pas ce n'est pas
un smartphone qui avertit fiction donc
pas certification d'étanchéité à l'eau
et à la poussière pour autant s'il pleut
ça devrait bien se passer une
certification c'est payant et c'est pour
ça que dans cette gamme de prix les
fabricants ne le font pas pour proposer
un produit au tarif le plus juste et
être concurrentiel or si on résume
divertissement multimédia gaming je suis
d'accord on pourra pas de faire tourner
les jeux les plus performants bien
évidemment parce que on va pas avoir le
processeur le plus performant néanmoins
pour faire tourner beaucoup de jeu du
plextor vous l'aurez sans aucun problème
donc c'est vrai que la mission est
remplie ici pour écouter divertissement
vous avez dit fier que vous avez mick
hannah spotify aux animaux loto vous
allez tout ce que vous voulez dès lors
vous avez un abonnement et que vous
payez vous pouvez faire tourner moto
sans abonnement pour regarder la télé
bon youtube également donc comme ça
venait voir sur youtube ça ira très bien
donc il remplit parfaitement son rôle
mais comme n'importe quel smartphone
aujourd'hui pour le gaming également
l'expérience est plutôt bonne le
processeur médiathèque fonctionne plutôt
bien l'autonomie est convenable on a un
smartphone qui est dans les clous pour
un smartphone au tarif de 229 euros 90
en version 4 64 et 269 euros 90 pour 628
je vous recommande la version 628 il
vous faut du stockage 64 giga ça sera
pas suffisant si vous faites beaucoup de
photos si vous avez des je souhaite
beaucoup de sauvegarde à l'intérieur
bien que vous puissiez augmenter jusqu'à
1 tera je vous recommande quand même la
version 128 ans il ya 40 euros d'écart
c'est marrant parce que sur le m3 on
avait 20 euros d'écart entre la version
64 et 128 ici 40 euros d'écart il reste
malgré tout un smartphone bien
positionnés en termes de tarifs par
rapport à ce qu'il vous propose à
l'intérieur je trouve plutôt honnête
j'aime bien ce touché très doux très
soyeux au dos du smartphone donc pour
moi ça smartphones qui est intéressant
si vous aimez la marque shiomi la marque
poko bien évidemment si vous aimez
l'expérience me why si vous voulez un
bon rapport qualité prix qui en fera
beaucoup mais qui fera pas tout je vous
mets tous les liens en bas dans la
description cliquer dessus pour trouver
au meilleur prix vous faire plaisir avec
ce pot coësmes quatre pros si vous avez
des questions vous connaissez l'histoire
se passe tout en bas dans les
commentaires sur ce mode vous embrasse
tous deux rendez vous très bientôt
continue à parler tech et puis moi je
vais continuer à tester sa yam amusé il
faut que je joue bien évidemment donc
vais jouer allez bisous cas auparavant
je vais monter la vidéo mais après j'ai
joué à vous ai compris l'histoire
[Musique]